today i'm going to be speaking with
danelle dixon who's the ceo
and executive director of stellar
danelle great to have you on today thank
you so much it's privileged to be here
so let's let's just start with we'll
we'll get into stellar
as well as the stellar development
foundation but generally speaking you
know i remember
i guess it was almost a decade ago going
to an event
at amherst college in massachusetts and
hearing about
bitcoin for the first time and a bunch
of people at the time you know threw a
thousand dollars at it and i think like
pennies on the coin or something like
that
now we have a situation where you turn
on cnbc they're talking about the price
of bitcoin all the time you've got so
many
uh large financial institutions even
suggesting to to clients you know maybe
one two percent of assets could be
in bitcoin or other cryptocurrencies are
we
even close to calling this space a
mature space at this point or is this
still really the early days
that's such a great question i i liken
it to
the early days of the web when folks
were starting to use
the web technologies it wasn't super
user friendly yet
it was a little harder to get on most
people had dial up
uh so i i liken it to that period of
time so i think that we're moving
into um what i would call like the
the late adolescent years um and you
know and i think the internet by the way
is in like the
you know the the more mature years of
like the 20s 30s
so i think that that's the way that i
would think about it in
in terms of what regulation might look
like
of digital assets and cryptocurrency if
if we're only at that relatively early
stage that you say
my guess is the regulatory environment
is not today what it will eventually
settle on do you agree with that
yeah i think that the the regulatory
environment i think the regulators and
policy makers learned a lot from
the the content side of the web and how
they uh sort of jumped in and tried to
regulate different components of the
content side of the web and realized
that
it's very challenging to do so because
the technology just like
outpaces the regulation so really try to
take a step back and say let's regulate
it a more principled level
i do see that while we do have some
things here and there
where we do have regulators kind of jump
in and make knee jerk decisions
i think that we're going to see a bit
more thought go into this and a bit more
and relying on the things that we
learned when we when in the early days
of the web so
i don't think the regulation is is what
it's going to be
but i also believe that unlike those
early days of the web
here the governments and regulators and
policymakers
have always known how to regulate fiat
and
a lot of these entities are touching
fiat so they're already regulated
so i think about we've learned i think
there might not be as many gaps
as sort of my um my my view of this and
we just need to get regulators and
policy makers comfortable
with this new technology and all the
value that it brings what do you think
is the biggest single question around
regulation
is it tax handling is it are these
securities
is it the kind of transnational issues
that exist with blockchain or something
else
i think honestly i think the tax is
mostly resolved right like we
at least here in the u.s and i think in
other countries that focus on that then
i think it's mostly a resolved issue
the securities question is going to be
one that's debated for a bit but i think
that you know
that is also i think on its way towards
resolution i think that
the the more challenging issues are
going to be with the notion of how to
handle something that is
not really it could be borderless right
i think that
i think that countries get a little
nervous about what happens when
uh you can't regulate something to the
degree that you want to
but we saw this with the web right the
web is out there and available
to everyone that's how we're doing this
conversation
and i think countries got comfortable
with that so i think that the more
challenging issues are just the fear
around
what could happen if something if
someone did something negative with this
technology
and i think that's incumbent on us those
in the industry to really work with
regulators
and policy makers to get them
comfortable and to help them to see the
value for their constituents
so then let's now talk a little bit
about stellar development foundation
and and then also the stellar network so
maybe talk a little bit about your
background
how you ended up here and and what sdf
and stellar are how they relate to each
other
right so the stellar development
foundation is a non-profit non-stock
entity
it is the entity that really have the
sole mission
is to create equitable access to the
global financial system
and we do that through the stellar
network by
really putting all of our efforts into
shepherding the code base
and into helping to create those network
effects in the ecosystem
so it's a lot like that just that
encapsulates why i'm here like i
i spent seven years at mozilla uh also
uh focused on
nonprofit mission-driven work really
focused on
really creating and sustaining this open
web and the technologies underneath it
focusing on standards focusing on the
need for interoperability
all of those things really directly
apply here in the payment side of the
web
and really directly apply to the work
that we're doing at stuller so
i think that you know stellar itself is
an open permissionless decentralized
network which really focuses on
cross-border remittances
that's and also asset issuance and
allows
all these really innovative companies to
do some pretty phenomenal work on top of
it
so you know it like my history and
really
loving the parts of the web that allow
this
open transparent communication
uh sort of brought me over here to this
side to really see that i would love to
create more and more standards and
interoperability
and we see some of that at play now and
i think we just need to really so that
we don't make some of the same mistakes
that were made on the content side of
the web
we really need to focus on making sure
that here we
continue to focus on standards and
interoperability so that we
have like what we want is for money to
move like email
and that's what we need to get to yes so
so stellar
allows money to to move and and to be
stored i'm
interested in hearing about some of the
specifics of the types of applications
that are possible built
built on stellar like what are what are
some tangible things people are doing
yeah so it's a great question i think
that you know sellers awesome for
payments and remittances cross-border
transactions really
is the thing it's also really great for
asset issuance so you take those two
things together and it creates this
really great opportunity
for companies that are financial
institutions so they're regulated by the
entities by the governments in their
geographies they can
issue for example let's take circle here
in the u.s they've issued a usdc
asset so it's a digital us dollar and
that runs you can use that on stellar to
be able to make a payment or send a
remittance to
someone who lives in nigeria for example
where there's another financial
institution
called kaori that actually has a digital
naira
uh so that you could transfer that value
in usdc
over there that can be easily converted
into the digital mira and then taken out
and put in a bank account there
so those kinds of transfers are
happening every day
on stuller so that's just one component
another really cool one um
there's several that i really love but
there's one that you know again focusing
on our work which is around equitable
access to this
the financial system and services d
stock is a company that takes
fractionalized or whole interest
in blue chip stocks and you can buy them
now anywhere and it's a digital
representation of it
uh but you can buy them now in south
africa so that you can be using your
mobile device there
in south africa and purchase blue chip
stocks of apple for example
uh that's pretty cool that is really
creating and making sure that everyone
has access to the same financial tools
and then of course we have all these
financial institutions right now there's
like 20 of them that have issued assets
on stellar in different geographies
that are ready and available and have
wallets that then leverage those assets
for the the regional interests of those
constituents right so
that we can't we don't know necessarily
where we sit with the problems that need
to be solved in all these geographies
but those folks do
so they can build on stellar wallets
they can build
these applications that allow for the
transfer of value they can issue these
assets and then it sort of creates this
borderless system that we think is
pretty remarkable one of the things that
seems
i mean it's not unique to this space it
exists in other spaces but it's often
brought up when you talk about oh
this is a project that will bank people
that are unbanked right now
in places where they may be depending on
you know
not particularly robust mobile phone and
spotty connections to
move assets or whatever the case may be
for for all the things on the pro side
of the ledger
in invariably people pop up and say oh
yeah but that would also make it easier
to
move funds for nefarious purposes or for
criminality or whatever like this this
has been around with bitcoin from the
very beginning now
the one counter is most criminal
activity is still funded with the dollar
not with digital assets but that if it
feels like it's falling a little short
to me because i think for me the more
interesting question is
as this matures as we are talking about
what sort of infrastructure will there
be to prevent that type of activity so
what what's your thought on that when
people talk about that issue
you're totally hitting the right issue i
don't think we can just say oh it's
funded by fiat now and especially the us
dollars so we don't have to think about
it we really
you know stellar has actually built in
compliance for those folks who issue
these assets so that they can actually
put compliance at like lots of different
levels and they can decide where they
want to do the kyc or the anti-money
laundering in
within the whether it's on redemption or
whether they actually uh when you
actually purchase the asset
but more importantly i i think that this
is actually an issue
that a lot of regulators are fearful of
and i just have to call out the fact
that
this is an immutable public record
so in in other circumstances when you're
dealing with fiat
you actually don't know where the fiat
is because you can't trace it unless
somehow you put tracers in it right like
which of course they do sometimes um but
with what with any kind of blockchain
technology especially public blockchains
it's immutable
it's out there it's available for anyone
to look at and the entity
that so then you can know the public
address as to where it went to
and then you can go back to the entity
that actually issued the asset
and then you can do still the same kind
of law enforcement use those tools to be
able to get access to the individuals
in a much more clean and robust way so
that now that's
if they are doing the proper kyc right
because if you if all you have is a
wallet address
that's essentially the dead end but
we're counting on
the direction where the platforms are
doing the kyc
yeah well and these entities again if
they touch fiat
they're going to be regulated assets
right on those sides so to get it off
the blockchain
they're going to have to touch fiat at
some point so you are counting on the
regulations actually being effective
which i for the most part think they are
they actually you know we've seen
already this this value in terms of
being able to follow the
the value on the blockchain in a much
easier way than you can do so outside of
it so
i don't think that i think that there
are actually more compliance and
value to a lot to law enforcement and to
lawmakers
when you look at these uh the digital
assets
but i also think that there's a lot more
freedom of movement which i think is
really
important so those two there's always
going to be we and we see this
every day on the content side of the web
with respect to arguments around privacy
you're always going to have healthy
tension that exists between
the notion of well we should just make
it so that everyone has to put their
name on the blockchain which of course
we would never want to see
um but there's a healthy tension between
how much
that of this you know from a privacy
standpoint and from a security
standpoint it's the same in blockchain
uh from the standpoint of really being
able to follow the money in a very very
direct way that you can't do
uh off-chain so i think that there's a
lot of value to it and this is an
argument
that i would love to stand up and have
conversations about because i think that
this shouldn't be the the
thing that actually creates fear in
regulators and lawmakers and i do think
it does
so putting fear aside for a moment
um a couple of years ago when i was
speaking to people involved in different
projects and we were talking about
right now what do you think is the
biggest barrier to much larger adoption
of you know at the time it was mostly
like
ethereum based projects and you know the
ecosystem has just grown so much and so
wide at this point
and the the views tended to vary from
well we're going to reach
a a point at which the limit is actually
going to be more like the number of
transactions that can actually be
processed
rather than a regulatory or legal limit
or a lack of interest from people
it's been a couple of years now like at
this point where
bitcoin is mostly mainstream but a lot
of these other
areas of the ecosystem are still
relatively niche
i guess we could say what do you think
over the next couple of years will be
the bottleneck in terms of the growth
yeah so i think that we what we have
is this really there's three things i
want to say a really deep need for focus
on
user solving user problems and doing it
in a way that's simple
not focusing so much on the technology
stack but making it so that it's really
easy
to be able to leverage this technology
so much so that a user wouldn't even
need to know
that the technology is being utilized i
think that's a really important thing
and we learned that in the days of the
web that you really needed to make it
simple
to be able to get on put your credit
card information and give people comfort
that this is a tool they can utilize
so that's the first thing so focusing on
really the consumer needs and solving
those problems for them and making it
really simple
the second thing is i think when you're
growing an ecosystem
one of the largest challenges is network
effects like i think that really
creating that
that value for everyone and remember
like you bring one player onto the
network
so that you can bring on three more but
they all want they all want volume
so everyone has to know that there's
value to them as they participate in
this ecosystem and as the ecosystem
grows
so that's certainly the network effects
issue it's an exciting challenge but
it's definitely a challenge
and then third i do think that you know
we've seen recently in nigeria for
example
where there have been some knee-jerk
reactions by some regulators to like
really be concerned and to like throw
you know throw some challenges in front
of the use of digital assets
i think we're also seeing by the way in
nigeria that folks are coming together
and having that
that public and private conversation
which i think we really need to have
with regulators
to leverage this like this really and
innovative tools these tools out there
and to really understand where the
public the governments are coming from
but regulation could be a barrier as
well but i think that those are the
three things i think if we get it right
on consumer
and and and frankly developer and making
it really simple
we're going to see these use cases blow
up and really really really take hold in
the mainstream we're already seeing it
uh as you say with respect to some but i
think we're going to see it more and
more if we can just solve those problems
yeah i mean as interesting as the last
two years have been the next two
um seem at least as interesting if
if not more um people can learn about
the stellar development foundation
at stellar.org foundation about stellar
at stellar.org we've been speaking with
the ceo and executive director of
stellar danelle dixon danelle so great
speaking to you today
wonderful to talk to you thanks for
having me